people are loving the babysitter
killer queen i mean everyone loved the
first one but what was it like for you
coming back as max without the shirt on
i mean people love this
um you know it's definitely the weirdest
character i've ever played
so getting the opportunity to jump back
in was really fun
originally there was one scene where i
was written with a shirt on i had a
had two wardrobe fittings one was for my
jeans and my belt buckle
and the other one was for the the
flashback scene where you meet me
um in working at like the little diner
and originally they had me in like a you
know kind of a dinery outfit with a hat
and i was talking to mcgee and i was
like
i feel like we've earned this no shirt
just
no shirt and like it doesn't have to
make sense it's not you know
max is in his own movie everyone else is
in
is in their own is in their movie and
max is in his own so uh
mcgee was like of course yes absolutely
so uh
you know i i hope people got a good
laugh out of the the name tag stuck to
skin and the hair net
okay so this is the picture you tweeted
then okay so how did
the name tag stay on that's just some
double stick tape or something
no pin through the skin okay good that
was definitely though
a laugh out loud moment watching this
movie you know in the first one
in the first movie your character got
killed off so did you
expect that there was going to be a
sequel that you'd be brought back
well i mean i'm kind of a um it's kind
of my thing to die and come back
uh so uh i figure why not with uh with
the babysitters well
um you know mcgee and mary who who are
amazing
uh director and producer of the movie
had talked to
myself and batch occasionally about
doing another one i'm sure they
talked to some of the other cast but uh
um
batch and mary and i were hanging out
one time and she was like we have an
idea for a sequel
and we were like well are we coming back
and she's like yeah of course so um
you know it was really cool i had heard
about it but
it never feels real until you're
shooting and um
you know hopefully we get to do it again
i feel like one you know
just cause i'm dead doesn't mean i'm
gone exactly and there's that scene at
the end of the movie that
maybe gives a hint potentially there
could be another one which is exciting
for fans
you know i feel like as long as people
keep wanting to watch it
um it's not like it's not like
bringing people back takes you out of
the movie the movie's so weird that you
know you can get away with doing
doing ridiculous things so uh yeah i
mean a third one would be great the
movie is
is doing so well and getting messages
from people around the world where it's
you know in the top 10
or if not the number one movie on
netflix in their territory
so it's it's really cool yeah okay well
i do have a question though i mean your
shirt's off throughout the whole movie
you're doing these
night scenes you're on the water at one
point i mean did you get cold
i did i was you know it's los angeles so
it could have been worse
you know yeah we weren't shooting in in
canada or anything but
you know we were we were about 40
minutes north of valet
and it was a little bit more deserty
than los angeles is and it gets cold at
night we're shooting in november
and it was especially it was an
especially cold november
and um you know it definitely wasn't
ideal to be
shirtless but uh it was fun you know it
made it made it made getting up for the
scenes a little more
energetic yeah the stuff on the water
was freezing
it was myself and a stunt double it was
so cold and we were flying we were
actually going so fast
on that boat and you know as far as
doing my own stunts i always try and do
as much as they'll let me do and i was a
little surprised they let me do this
because you can't
hide a life jacket so it's just like
they they gave me
glow sticks in my pockets for the if i
got you know
tossed off the tube it's so dark on the
water that i had to just
hold the glow sticks up and and wait for
them to come
get me while i'm freezing my ass off
but um my stunt double and i we kept
swapping back and forth
um just to just to stay warm
and oh my god i didn't do i mean granted
i didn't do the fire stunt that was all
him because that is way above my pay
grade but um
it was it was fun you know that's like
that's you know that's one of my
favorite parts of shooting these movies
but it was a little scary for sure
yeah well let me tell you it was worth
it because that whole scene i mean i
literally thought is he really on that
two
because those guys are flying like that
oh yeah we were moving i got dumped off
once and i think i
skidded or skipped a couple times across
the
wall without your shirt on
i know i was like a little pebble just
flying across the lake
um well i want to also say
congratulations on upload with season
two how excited was that for you to hear
that news especially a week after it
it premiered you know
we we were so excited about the show but
um i've been a product part of projects
that i thought were great it didn't make
it and
projects that i thought were okay that
did well so you know there's
there's not always um a real rhyme or
reason why something
succeeds so it was very relieving
um you know for the show to find its fan
base and i'm still getting messages from
people finding it now
and um i'm really proud of the show i
can't wait to get back to season two
we're gonna start shooting in
january in vancouver um and um
yeah i just you know i love the cast i
love the the crew
and i love the role so i'm excited to
jump back in
yeah now is there any concerns about
kind of how different things will be now
you know after
cobia 19 and all the precautions that
are going to take place
yeah i mean you know some some stuff has
already gone back
i have some friends that are on projects
i'm starting a project fairly soon
and learning about um kind of how the
the safety precautions are working
a lot of testing um being divided into
groups based on uh kind of necessity of
proximity with other people
um and you know i think that everybody
will just do their best
um i know the cast uh of upload is is
really exciting to get back but also
you know very cautious about how
how to handle everything and um you know
the nice thing is in canada the numbers
are are fairly low and we shoot in
vancouver so
hopefully they they stay low or continue
to you know to get lower by the time we
shoot
in january yeah um now so many people
have had so much down time a lot of
people spent so much time with their
family you have a little baby at home
with it what is that family time been
like for you over the past couple of
months
it's great tomorrow's his first birthday
oh and it's so exciting i know
i know it's crazy that he's won um he's
amazing he's
he's really smart he's really funny he's
enormous he's like 31 pounds and he's
only a year old he's
just huge um he's gonna be so much
bigger than me
by the time he's like 12. um he's great
he's so much fun and you know my wife
and i
both being actors it's it's really nice
to have had the time home
to to watch him develop and be there for
you know every little step that we may
not have been if
if one of us was shooting somewhere so
um you know it's just kind of a silver
lining to um
to uh to covet or to to the you know
where the world is right now
yeah oh i love that and we recently um
did some interviews with the cast of eat
wheaties
um which oh cool you've had some really
funny scenes in with tony hale
uh what was it like working on that
project i'm such a huge fan of veep so
my agent phoned me and he was like do
you want to do this movie he's like it's
a small role but you know this is the
cast and i was like yes
a hundred percent um and uh you know
director was great writer was great
uh cass was fantastic uh very very very
funny people um
tony hail i you know i i only worked for
them a couple days and i just asked him
so many questions about beef it's one of
my favorite shows so just getting to
work with him was
was amazing and he could not have been
any nicer more accommodating
for someone who was only there in a
short period of time but um i saw the
movie the movie's
super fun and super weird and i think
people will dig
it um you know i'm just glad to be a
part of it
yeah it's nice when you love a show when
you love the actors then they turn out
to be awesome as well
it's way better than the other way
around yeah i know because that's
definitely happened to all of us i swear
you